وانت قاعده تشتغل دائما على مشروعين ام هي
صدفه الان يعني الافضل ان يشتغل المراه
على مشروع واحد يكرس له وقته ونفسه وجهده
وتفكيره لكن فعلا كما اشرت تاتي مصادفات
جميله وعجيبه فيجد المرء نفسه يشتغل على
مستويين وعلى طاولتين وفي افقيين مختلفين
مختلفين من حيث الموضوع ولكن كل موضوع هو
امتداد لاهتماماتي وانشغالات الفكريه
والنقديه والادبيه اشتغل الان
حول كتاب وهي وهو حول لهم بارت في المغرب
المنظر الادبي الكبير
والسنيولوجي الفرنسيه الاشهر في العالم
كان المغرب في ستنيات كسائح ثم جاء الى
المغرب سنه 69 70 كاستاد في كليه الاداب
في الرباط استقر في مدينه الرباط واصبحت
له امكنه
واص له الشله اصدقاؤه الى اخره وهو جاي من
باريس في ربيع الشباب
تقريبا من ضجيج ربيع باريس سنه 68
وجعل المغرب واطمئن الى هذا البلد والى
جغرافيا هذا البلد وذاكره هذا البلد وكتب
كثير من الاشياء حول المغرب وكتابه
وقائع كله حول المغرب بل حتى كتابه
البوستن الذي صدر بعد وفاته كتاب الحداد
الذي يتضمن شضارات حول والدته عندما ماتت
وتركت جرحا عميقا في نفسه ايضا هناك
تجليات واشارات متعدده للمغرب
طبعا
الى عنوان يعني اظن كل ربما انا لا اعرف
يعني هذا الباب
البروتوكول الملكي تاريخيا من هذه الزاويه
يعني شو اللي في الحقيقه اخي احمد عندما
كنت اشتغل حول اطروحه الدكتوراه حول الشعر
الشفوي والموسيقى التقليديه في المغرب
اخترت
لون او نوع موسيقي تقليدي مغربي
وانا ابحث في المصادر وفي المخطوطات وفي
الكتب والمراجع اجيد اشارات متعدده
تاريخيا الى البروتوكول الملكي في المغرب
كان يسمى التشريفات السلطاني لما كان
المغرب سلطنه مره عليه وحكمه عدد من
سلاطين الاسر والسلالات السابقه من
الادارسه المرابطين للموحدين الى
المرينيين الى الوطن السعوديين الى
السعوديين ثم الى الاسره الحاكمه الحاليه
العلويين همم اشارات متعدده واجد ان هناك
سلاطين
الان اولى واهتماما كبيرا للاحتفال
السياسي
ولاشكال وتعبيرات البروتوكول فكنت اؤشر
على هذه الاشياء واقول لابد انا عوده الى
هذا الموضوع فعت اليه وسجلت اطروحه
دكتورتين الاخرى لاحفز نفسي ليس لشيء اخر
لاحفز نفسي على الاشتغال وعلى البحث وعلى
الذهب يوميا الى المكتبه الوطنيه